and some of these character ideas are
you watching people when you go to
Starbucks is that is that the only
reason to go to Starbucks but you know
where are you coming up with some of
these ideas for these characters I think
every writer carries are in a locker a
locker and they just suck stick ideas
narrow and periodically they pull them
out and redress them and it's funny like
you do look back and somebody gonna
realize where they're coming from you go
I pulled that from this but like I
there's things that you just kind of
stick unto your your mental you know
collage of your life like you know
pieces of conversation how about my wife
will go in there that'll end up in the
script or you know someone that you from
high school or a character here so
instant it's an emotion you know a lot
of favor you know I'm of the perfect
generation to really be befuddled by
Facebook by social media because most of
my life you know prior to social media
someone fell out of your life they were
out of your life like if you didn't
write him a letter you know they were
gone like high school junior high early
in my career college a lot of people
just thought of fell out of out of out
of the way and then when Facebook came
about suddenly all the stages of your
life were in the same time you have a
former employer you're 20 and a high
school friend and your daughter and a
current frontiers and your mom all
commenting on you know your status
update and they're all talking to each
other and it's very strange to see like
someone I knew in junior high as someone
that I worked on a film when I was 25
and my kid all commenting on a picture
of my Christmas tree it's just very
strange and you find yourself being
approached by people that you didn't
necessarily like way back then or didn't
have our or you did that you have
nothing in common with now suddenly
friending you on facebook and all of a
sudden they're commenting on your feet
and and not always positively in a
strange and that was a situation where
as a guy that I didn't really I got her
friends in seventh grade eighth grade
forward we didn't get along at all
couldn't stand the guy
didn't talk to him didn't end well
friends me in facebook 20 years later no
hi no hoes I get out like oh god okay
well I guess I felt obliged to accept it
I don't know why I did and then he was
completely acidic on everything i posted
he turned everything into a political
thing and you know very right-wing I'm
left wing but whatever like I'll have to
discuss politics in a Facebook doesn't
have to be you know but he would turn
everything into that I've no I picture
my kid uh I've no idea why I got really
sick of it in one point I got so angry
I'll tell him off I'm like why why am I
doing this I don't see this person you
don't live in the same state as me know
no real world friends in common we're
not related to look together like why am
i friends this guy because we were both
in a the same starting line when I was
11 so i defriended him and I didn't tell
him I didn't make a thing about I just
literally unclick she friended him and
it became this thing where like
everybody from our high school was like
you know pro me or con me and I was wise
worth its obligation coming from this
strange social obligation to maintain
these expired friendships he has expired
relationships and so a lot of the
emotional core of favorite came from
that experience weirdly enough you know
I didn't necessarily intend it to be
that way it wasn't like I'd turned that
into a story but as I began to write
this story for me that became a part of
it and it formed a lot of the characters
and a lot of the subtext of the storm
interesting i've heard of other people
going through that where someone from
their past will come out and they'll
comment and it's not necessarily yeah
you know praising that person it's it's
very odd no keep mine there people that
came out of my past that are I haven't
talked to and thought about yours and
they're great like oh wow totally cool
people that people that I shouldn't
think in common with but we get along we
have this to be this common interest and
we still a go see them and what's great
but it doesn't mean just because someone
you did know somebody back then doesn't
mean you necessarily need to be friends
of them now and and Facebook has sort of
created this social obligation
absolutely
to be friends then we're just because
you know them regardless of whether or
not you should be and that's sort of
what I was responding to even though
Facebook doesn't there's no social media
computer anything in the movie but that
emotion of obligation is what I drew
from when I was writing a lot of favor
that makes sense yeah interesting
you